♪ ♪
>> Juan: A WILD STORY GETTING
A LOT OF ATTENTION.
THE NOW CEO OF OVERSTOCK.COM
FORCED TO RESIGN THIS WEEK.
CLAIMS THAT HE WAS INVOLVED IN
THE RUSSIA PROBE, PATRICK BYRNE
LAYING OUT HIS EXPLOSIVE
ALLEGATIONS INCLUDING THAT HE
WAS ORDERED TO HAVE AN AFFAIR
WITH THE RUSSIAN SPY.
WATCH.
>> WE ARE THE GOOD GUYS, OH, WE
DON'T WORK LIKE THE BAD GUYS,
BUT WE NEED TO ASK YOU TO
REKINDLE A ROMANTIC
RELATIONSHIP.
I WAS SPECIFICALLY TOLD THIS
REQUEST IS COMING FROM JIM COMEY
AT THE RESPECTIVE SOMEBODY.
I WAS GIVEN SOME FISHY ORDERS,
AND IT CARRIED THEM OUT THINKING
IN 2015, 2015 I WOULD BE
LAW ENFORCEMENT.
LAST TIME I WAS WATCHING
TELEVISION AND SOME
CONGRESSIONAL HEARINGS, I
FIGURED OUT WHERE THEY CAME
FROM, A GUY NAMED TITO
PETER STRZOK, THIS WAS ESPIONAGE
AGAINST HILLARY CLINTON, RUBIO,
CRUZ, AND TRUMP.
>> Juan: SO YOU HAD THIS ON
YOUR SHOW LAST NIGHT, ON "THE
STORY" AND MY EYEBROWS WERE
FLIPPING OUT.
THESE ARE BIZARRE CLAIMS, BUT
NOT ONLY ON YOUR SHOW, BUT
SEVERAL NETWORKS AND EVERYBODY
SEEMS TO THINK, THERE IS
SOMETHING CREDIBLE HERE.
IT IS NOT ALL TO BE DISMISSED.
>> Martha: WE WILL SEE.
AND I WOULD NOT PUT THEM ON THE
SHOW IF I DID NOT HAVE
INDICATIONS FROM PEOPLE CLOSE TO
THE INVESTIGATION THAT THE --
>> Greg: JESSE WOULD HAVE.
>> Martha: THAT HIS STORY MAY
BE TRUE, NOT THAT IT IS, BUT
THERE IS A SUGGESTION THAT HE
COULD BE TELLING THE TRUTH.
SO WE ASKED HIM A LOT OF
QUESTIONS AND GIVEN AN
OPPORTUNITY TO TELL HIS STORY.
I REALLY LET THEM TALK, BECAUSE
I WANTED TO SEE WHERE HE WAS
GOING TO GO.
BECAUSE HE WANTS TO GET SOME OF
THIS OFF OF HIS CHEST.
AND I DID SPEAK WITH HIM TODAY
AND SAY WHAT IS YOUR REACTION TO
THE FACT THAT JAMES COMEY CAME
OUT AND ANDREW MCCABE CAME OUT
AND SAID THAT THEY DID NOT KNOW
HIM AND THAT'S NOT THE WAY
THINGS WORK AT THE FBI, I
THOUGHT IT WAS INTERESTING THAT
ANDREW MCCABE SAID SOME OF THE
THINGS THAT HE DESCRIBED ARE NOT
TO THE WAY THINGS HAPPEN IN THE
FBI.
SO I DON'T KNOW WHICH FALLS INTO
THE CATEGORY OF ART AND ARE NOT,
BUT HE SAID THEY WERE LYING
THROUGH THEIR TEETH.
>> Katie: THERE IS HISTORY OF
THAT.
IT'S NOT LIKE JAMES COMEY AND
ANDREW MCCABE ARE TRUTHFUL.
>> Martha: PEOPLE USED TO SAY
THAT THEY KNOW EXACTLY WHO HE IS
AND MORE TO COME.
>> Juan: YOU ARE A MAN OF
GREAT DISCRETION WHEN IT COMES
TO THESE MATTERS.
>> Greg: I DON'T THINK HE
MEANT THAT.
>> Katie: >> Juan: YES, I
DO.
I WAS THINKING THIS WAS A SPY
NOVEL, THIS GOES LIKE, HE SAYS
WARREN BUFFETT IS HIS OMAHA A
RABBI, RIGHT?
AND MARIA BUTINA IS THIS RUSSIAN
SPY.
HE IS HELPING THE FBI
INVESTIGATE HILLARY CLINTON.
SO HOW DOES THIS STRIKE YOU?
IS HE TELLING THE TRUTH?
OR IS IT A DESPERATE BRAND?
>> Jesse: BIG IF TRUE.
I HAVE BEEN EATING MY DEEP STATO
I HAVE BEEN EATING MY DEEP STATR
I HAVE BEEN EATING MY DEEP STATA
I HAVE BEEN EATING MY DEEP STATL
I HAVE BEEN EATING MY DEEP STATN
I HAVE BEEN EATING MY DEEP STATG
I HAVE BEEN EATING MY DEEP STATT
I HAVE BEEN EATING MY DEEP STATM
I HAVE BEEN EATING MY DEEP STAT.
AND THIS IS IT FOR ME.
YOU HAVE COMEY, YOU HAVE STRZOK,
THIS WILL TAKE ME PAST
LABOR DAY.
SO I'M HAPPY.
LET'S JUST SAY THAT THERE IS NO
WAY TO PROVE WHAT HE SAID AT
THIS POINT, BUT I AM OPEN MINDED
TO HEARING WHAT HE HAS TO SAY.
BECAUSE IT FITS THE FACT PATTERN
OF THE ROGUE AGENCY, THE FBI AND
TRAPPING PEOPLE, MANIPULATING
PEOPLE FOR POLITICAL REASONS.
AND YOU MENTIONED IT WHEN WE
DISCUSS THIS EARLIER, THIS GOES
BACK TO WHAT?
THE INSURANCE POLICY.
BECAUSE IF YOU HEARD WHAT HE
SAID, THEY WERE DOING THIS TO
MULTIPLE POLITICIANS.
HILLARY, RUBIO, CRUZ, TRUMP.
AND AS TRUMP IS THE PLAYER, THE
FOCUS GOES TO HIM.
NOW HE HAS SPOKEN TO JOHN
DURHAM, WHO IS RUNNING THE
INVESTIGATION OF THE
INVESTIGATORS.
>> Martha: LET ME JUST CLARIFY
THAT, BECAUSE WE TALKED ABOUT
THAT.
>> Jesse: HE OFFERED
INFORMATION.
A >> Martha: HE SPOKE TO
PEOPLE OF THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE ON APRIL 3RD AND APRIL
APRIL 5TH, HE GAVE HIM
EVERYTHING HE HAD.
THEN WHEN THE DURHAM
INVESTIGATION OPEN, IT GOT
TURNED OVER.
>> Jesse: WE COULD FIND OUT
WHEN THIS THING A SERVER IF HE
IS CRAZY OR TELLING THE TRUTH.
OR IT COULD BE CRAZY AND TELLING
THE TRUTH.
>> Juan: 80, THE THING IS, CAN
HE PROVE IT?
ARE THERE PICTURES OF HIM WITH
MARIA BUTINA?
>> Katie: THERE ARE.
>> Greg: I HAVE SEEN ONE.
>> Katie: THERE IS ONE.
THERE IT IS.
>> Juan: CAN HE PROVE THAT SHE
WAS IN FACT PUSHING HIM TO GET
CONTACTS INSIDE THE CLINTON
CAMPAIGN?
>> Katie: OBVIOUSLY THE ISSUE
IS HER PUSHING HIM, BUT THE
BIGGEST ISSUE IS THE FBI, THE
PEOPLE AT THE TOP GETTING THE
RANK-AND-FILE, THE MEN IN BLACK
PUSHING HIM TO HAVE THIS
RELATIONSHIP WITH HER IN ORDER
TO GAIN SOME KIND OF POLITICAL
INFORMATION ON ALL OF THE
CANDIDATES THAT TEAM MENTION.
SO THAT IS THE BIGGER QUESTION.
MARIA BUTINA HAS BEEN INDICTED,
SHE WAS CONVICTED.
AND IS IMPRISONED NOW.
SO SHE HAS BEEN DEALT WITH.
THE ISSUE THAT HE IS BRINGING UP
IS WHO WAS BEHIND THIS?
AND PROBABLY FEELING OUT THE
MEDIA LANDSCAPE TO SEE OUR
PEOPLE INTERESTED?
DO I GO FURTHER WITH THIS.
AND HE SHOULD BE THINKING ABOUT
GETTING A LAWYER, BECAUSE HE HAS
TWO CONCERNS IF THIS IS TRUE.
EITHER THAT THE GOVERNMENT SET
HIM UP BACK IN THE DAY WHEN THE
FBI WAS RUN AMOK AND
PETER STRZOK WAS RUNNING THE
SHOW AND SETTING UP THE RUSSIA
COLLUSION NARRATIVE, OR THAT
MAYBE HE ENGAGED IN SOME KIND OF
BAD BEHAVIOR THAT COULD CALM
LEGALITY ON THE OTHER END.
>> Juan: YOU KNOW, GREG, HERE
IS WHAT STRIKES ME.
HE NOW HAS A WEBSITE CALLED
DeepCapture.com .
AND IS TALKING ABOUT THE
SITH LORD, WHICH IS WALL STREET
AND SAYS THAT THEY ARE HIS
ENEMIES.
AND THEY ARE THE ONES THAT HE
HAS BEEN LEFT FROM
OVERSTOCK.COM, BECAUSE SETH
LORD AND THESE OVERSTOCK PEOPLE
ARE OUT TO BREAK HIM.
>> Greg: I SEE THREE OPTIONS
PAID ONE, HE IS TELLING THE
TRUTH.
TWO, HE IS TELLING THE TRUTH,
BUT --
>> Jesse: A LITTLE NUTS?
>> Greg: A LITTLE NUTS, THREE,
HE IS LEADING TO AN SEC
INVESTIGATION, THAT COULD BE A
WAY TO GET HIM, SO HE COULD
EASILY PUT THAT INTO THE
COMPARTMENT THAT IS PART OF THE
BIGGER CONSPIRACY.
I THINK THE ONLY WAY TO KNOW IS
IF OTHER PEOPLE WHO KNOW HIM SAY
SOMETHING IN THE NEXT COUPLE OF
DAYS.
ALIKE, HE HAS ISSUES, OR NO,
THIS IS TOTALLY OF LEGITIMATE,
HE HAS TALKED TO ME ABOUT IT.
BUT IF THEY SAY HE HAS BEEN
KNOWN TO SPIN TALES.
ESPECIALLY PEOPLE LIKE
WARREN BUFFETT, HE SHOULD SAY,
HE HAS TALKED TO ME ABOUT THIS.
IF YOU SAID THAT WAS LEGIT, I
WOULD BE ON FIRMER GROUND, BUT I